so i think in the majority of cases
abortion is a cop-out and the reason i
think this is because 40 of women that
get an abortion have had two or more
they're not they're not tracking which
women are going to get abortions in the
future so arguably that number could be
higher right and we have so many
different forms of birth control right
we have condoms we have iuds we have
that thing that they put in your arm
that are 99.5 percent effective 98 this
guy wanted to argue 98 that's still
that's still pretty effective right so
we have all these ways that we can
prevent pregnancies and if you still get
pregnant it's a cop-out for your poor
decision
i mean i don't completely disagree but i
don't know if i completely agree either
okay a lot of people argue that okay so
what about people who are financially
unable to look after the child
or they
you know are raped or things of this
nature i know that's a that's a minority
so this is one misconception is that
poor people get abortions at higher
rates than richer people so actually
only eight percent of women below the
poverty line are getting abortions where
one out of three women that make forty
seven thousand dollars per year or more
are getting an abortion so it's the
majority of the women that are that are
getting these abortions can't afford it
right okay and so to me it's like
if you make 47k where a year you can you
can afford condoms right so it's really
it seems like the majority are just it's
a fail-safe or a poor reproductive
choice that you made
why do you think
abortion is pushed so much why do you
think it's something that is like really
heavily pushed by the media by certain
influences and we see it so much
nowadays especially as a younger
generation honestly i think so this is
something a lot of people don't know
about do you know where planned
parenthood's roots in the us
yeah and so i think there's a group of
elites honest this is this is a
conspiracy don't i know the comments are
going to be like you do
this is this is this part is conspiracy
but i think there's a group of elites
that believe in population control and i
think that's why they're doing it and
that's why 80 percent of planned
parenthoods in the u.s are in minority
communities the black population in the
us would be double today
yeah she referred to black people as
weeds and so it's like if nike was
founded by a racist people would be on
the streets why is this okay especially
when margaret singer's grandson they
talk about how they want to market it to
minority women and they talk about how
they wanna they make it a woman of color
issue and like that's that's how they
market it to minority in that her
project is called the n-word project her
grandson is still doing it he's in new
york he was the head of planned
parenthood in all of new york and he was
interviewed about roe versus wade and he
uses the same language like this affects
women of color when anyone can get an
abortion it's not it's not specifically
i think that's something a lot of people
should know about the roots of planned
parenthood
especially when it ties to race and
minority populations in america
a lot of people will say that
removing
the choice to get an abortion is an
infringement on women's rights and that
it's going to keep kind of coming after
women's rights and that kind of thing so
it kind of brings in a feminist movement
with are they going to go after women's
votes are they going to go after women
being able to do this and do that so
what do you think about that in terms of
a women's rights perspective what about
the child's rights it's like i think the
child's rights at conception there's a
unique dna sequence that's different
from the mother and the father right
that dna sequence has the eye color hair
color personality traits um and in china
you see you see something where they're
aborting women that's because of the one
child policy so what what about those
women so and that's that's the problem
with abortion is it becomes a slippery
slope to eugenics where a lot of the
arguments i hear people make are
something along the lines of poor people
should shouldn't live and shouldn't be
alive when everyone on earth is richer
than most people were in all of human
history you know by that logic no one
should be
i think a lot of people also get caught
up with um the whole
point of life discussion so a lot of
people who are kind of pro life will say
that as soon as um the sperm and the egg
kind of come together that is somewhat a
form of life starting but it seems to be
this kind of um as you said like
slippery stuff as to where life starts
and i think if i don't think i
personally don't demonize those who are
pro-life or pro-choice because i think
they both come from a point of like i
see where they're coming from both sides
i feel like one side gets heavily
demonized and the conversation just gets
completely skewed
that's why i didn't want to answer you
over there because as soon as i say
pro-life nobody wants to hear anything
yeah which which isn't it's not really
fair because another thing is a lot of
people i think if they saw what
abortions looked like they wouldn't they
wouldn't be cool with it
they pull off the limbs one by one they
crush the head and they vacuum it out
for surgical abortions yeah and and if
they did that to puppies people would be
an uproar yeah yeah it's weird because
when it's a human
yeah and like again this isn't something
and i also a lot of people say oh you
know as men yeah we shouldn't have an
opinion on this kind of stuff yeah
something interesting that you as a
woman who you know seems to kind of have
a a fork in the discussion
is giving your opinion because if i was
here with this
no one would bother listening to me as a
woman i think it's important that women
have this discussion amongst themselves
and try to like have a dialogue that
kind of looks at both sides of the
spectrum
but i think the last two weeks the whole
roe v wade thing yeah it was you
couldn't escape it like i was exactly
sure where i was with it because again
i'm not gonna say i'm pro-life or
pro-choice
i think there are some ex some
situations where i don't blame a woman
for getting an abortion again if she's
underage and she's in that kind of i get
that but um
you know when it is used as a form of
contraception as you said that most
people get two or more that to me just
seems like a sort of contraception and
that is something that i difficult
people know about if they if they knew
that abortion was as a form of
contraception maybe the discussion be a
bit different i think do you know what
her programming is i've heard the term i
can't tell exactly
is basically like women date across and
up hierarchies and so a girl wants to
know when she has a kid that's the best
i can do so that's why you see a lot of
girls chasing after rich guys trying to
get their kids right and to me abortion
is the ultimate form of hypergamy
because she's saying this isn't the best
i could do because if a girl is really
into you she she's not aborting that kid
you couldn't pay her okay
that's interesting i mean i can't no no
one no one's aborting steph curry's kid
no one's important
that's that's an interesting part of the
conversation how finance how economics
how social status plays a part into it i
get that that makes a lot of sense a lot
of people say things like oh especially
me as a man you know you're not carrying
the child
you know you can't say what whatever
whatever i think you may have a point in
there as well i mean again i would love
to say devil's advocate to what you're
saying but everything you're kind of
saying the things i fought myself
but i don't say publicly per se
because
until now but again
when i found out the roots of um planned
parenthood margaret sanger eugenics
reducing the black population that's
something i can't ignore yeah right so a
lot of black people should know this
kind of a lot of minority people should
know this stuff about where the whole
push for um abortion came from
especially our communities you know it's
not something that we should just really
nearly go along with do your research
find things out for yourself don't just
go along with what the media and
everything everyone's telling you
because history will say something
different and that's the crazy thing is
i i don't understand why people don't
freak out about this information like
and it's the same people running the
organizations like it's not like it's a
new new people and a lot of times the
arguments you hear about abortion are
honestly a form of eugenics which which
indicate that people of lower iq should
be exterminated people that are poor
should be exterminated i don't think
people know that's what they're arguing
but when they start to bring out well
she can't afford those kids well most
people are richer today than they ever
could have been in human history poor
people have air well not in the uk y'all
don't have air conditioning here but but
poor people have smart phones nobody in
history could have had that right okay
so in terms of the whole kind of um
discussion around abortion in that so
i'm guessing you're american yeah i am
do you think there's a difference
between how americans view the
conversation around how british people
view the conversation people are more
left like people are a lot more
pro-choice here in my experience like
people are more like angry more angry
yeah about it like when i bring this son
out i'm like more scared here
i'm not i mean it's fine but like it's
just i i find that like there's more
people that agree with me in the u.s
interesting interesting it depends where
you are though if i went to la that
would probably be a different absolutely
absolutely i mean again i think the
whole kind of thing with for pro-choice
and for life is a bit again even to me
that's a bit skewed because pro-choice
is okay everyone should have a choice in
life i suppose everyone should have a
choice to do whatever they want right
but and then you got pro-life is
basically saying i want these children
to live and i don't know i feel like
it's not exactly fair because if you're
pro-life it's like oh you're the most
extreme person ever we cancel you put
you out of any sort of like civil
discourse but then if you're pro-choice
you can be pro-choice but for the most
part still want to tell to live on most
occasions so you can actually be
pro-choice but more in common with
someone who's pro-life than someone
who's really like oh pro-abortion yeah
get it get it get it all the time so
i feel like even that is still a bit
skewed i don't think it's a it's a fair
point to kind of you know you know it's
a crazy stat too do you know when
abortion's legal here what when or why
like how long how long uh it's not been
that long i believe in northern ireland
it's still not no no i meant like how
long like how far along i can get an
abortion in a pregnancy
i actually really enjoyed talking to
these two people because
they were just very open to like
listening and learning and
i really enjoy conversations where i
feel like i'm learning from them they're
learning from me we're both open to
different ideas and it's not just a
heated debate or you know i believe what
i believe regardless of any facts data
or statistics
yeah
six months oh so no do you know the
earliest child that survived birth like
survived
like four or five months or something
like that yeah 21 weeks and it's legal
up to 24. yeah see
some of these kids like could
hypothetically yeah it could be real
living people breathing people so that
to me again i can't after you saying
that i can't pretend like that sits
right with me yeah it doesn't and i
don't think a lot of people know in five
months long six months so long then you
terminate the pregnancy only in
situations where the mum the mother
could die yeah most pro-lifers would
agree with that when it's the life of
the mother most pro-lifers would agree
that i can understand that but if
there's not a true health risk going on
i would really struggle to find peace
with somebody doing that i really would
so